[Music]
on this Friday night fresh bombs and
bloodshed as the fighting resumes
between Israel and
Hamas the people in the region who
fiercely support Hamas and why Canada
adds tens of thousands of jobs what it
might mean for interest rates and why
some businesses are struggling to grow
Congress Liar Liar excuse me the Litany
of falsehoods leading to this
Republican's extraordinary expulsion
from
Congress and a heartwarming story of
warming up the less fortunate I think I
would like to do something for these
folks the lottery winners who are paying
it
forward and what the Ontario kangaroo
that has police
popping global national with far
Asser it lasted one week minutes after
the temporary ceasefire deal between
Israel and Hamas broke down Israel
pounded Gaza with more than 200 air
strikes the Hamas R health authority is
reporting more than 175 people have been
killed today alone rocket fire from Gaza
was intercepted by Israel's Iron Dome
good evening both sides are trading
blame for ending the pause and fighting
while negotiators inq are trying to
restart it the US is reaffirming its
support for Israel while also
reinforcing ing the need to keep people
caught in the middle safe I made clear
that after the pause it was imperative
that Israel put in place clear
protections for civilians uh and for
sustaining humanitarian assistance uh
going forward but as Crystal ganing
Reports in our top story tonight Israel
is indicating a widening offensive in
southern Gaza and a warning some of the
images here are
disturbing with the return of Israeli
air strikes came the flood of images of
bloodied children and panicked
parents what is it exactly it's just a
house with civilians who fled from other
areas says this resident noting there
were many children in the home Israel
warned people in Gaza to move further
south to Rafa but it was hit today as
was Han Yunis a southern city Israeli
forces previously said would be a safe
location but now terms Han Yunis a
dangerous combat zone this Hospital
simply cannot take more children with
the wounds of War there are children
everywhere these children are sleeping
there was a bomb literally 50 m from
here Israel says Hamas violated the
terms of the Paw by failing to release
all of the hostages in the latest
promised group and for firing Rockets
towards Israel having chosen to hold on
to our women Hamas will now take the
mother of all thumpings that's thumping
as it was described also strikes the
heart of Israeli families fearing for
loved ones still being held captive in
Gaza we called the government to bring
them whole um to bring them uh as many
as is possible not as 8 or 10 as many as
possible like 30 or 50 together as bombs
dropped new questions were raised about
what Israeli officials knew about the
possible attack by Hamas and when the
New York Times is reporting that details
were shared more than a year ago with
Israeli leaders plans that were eily
similar to The Deadly events that
unfolded on October 7th including the
use of rockets at the start of the
attack and gunmen flooding into Israel
the times reports that Israeli officials
dismissed the attack calling it
aspirational prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu has been widely criticized for
National Security failures but so far
has yet to take
responsibility Israeli officials say
more than 1,200 Israelis were killed on
that day and more than 200 taken hostage
in the fighting that's followed more
than 15,000 Palestinians have been
killed 40% are children according to the
Hamas ran Health Ministry Crystal ganing
Global News
London with the war reigniting in Gaza
questions are once again rling about
Israel's goal of eliminating Hamas and
who may take over if that goal is
accomplished the renewed fighting leaves
a political future of the Palestinian
people more uncertain than ever in both
Gaza and in the occupied West Bank
Danielle hamam Jan
reports Friday prayers in
ramala the longer the bombs Keep Falling
on Gaza the stronger the support here
will likely be for the militants ruling
over
it the green shadowy figure can be
spotted all over it's Hamas military
commander Muhammad
Dave his fan base is only growing in the
West Bank which is occupied by Israel I
support Hamas we support M they say they
support the
resistance and at this moment in time
Hamas is seen by most as the only
effective Palestinian resistance against
Israel prior to October 7th you wouldn't
have had such public display of support
for Hamas uh you'll see the the Hamas
flag over there the green flag but you
also have to understand that what people
support is our right for resistance and
what they support is resistance against
Israeli
occupation and they don't understand why
Israel and so many other countries in
the world are trying to deprive
Palestinians from the right of resisting
if we resist in a military way they call
it
terrorism parts of the West Bank are
administered by the Palestinian
Authority which hasn't held elections in
17 years the man at the top is Mahmud
abas who is widely regarded as corrupt
and working hand inhand with Israel to
ensure Security in the occupied
territory and that is only fueling the
anger among
[Applause]
Palestinians and it's not the
Palestinian Authority that negotiated
the release of 240 Palestinian prisoners
but
Hamas we were suffering from the cold
without electricity she said and no one
helped
us only Hamas
cared the US is clear on what the future
here should look like there should be
two states one for is Israelis and one
for Palestinians then we can have a
Palestinian State including West Bank
Gaza and East
Jerusalem with one condition that Israel
must EV all their settlers from the
occupied West Bank you think that's
realistic yes why not there are nearly
700,000 Israeli settlers living in the
West Bank and East Jerusalem Washington
has now informed Israeli officials that
they will soon impose Visa bans on
extremist settlers engaged in violence
against
Palestinians far Danielle hamon in
Jerusalem for us thank you in Winnipeg
Police have arrested a man linked to
Sunday's deadly mass
shooting at 6:30 this morning with the
assistance of General Patrol and our
tactical support team the suspect was
safely taken into custody this is still
very much an ongoing
investigation 32-year-old Jamie Randy
Felix is charged with four counts of
second deegree murder and one count of
attempted murder he is known to police
but his relationship to the victims is
still unclear A 55-year-old man is still
in hospital in critical condition two
Montreal area organizations that serve
the Chinese Community say they're
planning to take legal action against
the RCMP in March the RCMP publicly
alleged both organizations were hosting
Chinese government agents who they say
harassed members of Montreal's Chinese
Community the organizations say that
investigation caused people to lose
their jobs and it led to major funding
Cuts they're now seeking $2.5 million in
Damages and are calling on the RCMP to
retract the allegations and deliver a
public apology the RCMP says the
investigation is
ongoing there are some troubling new
signs about the health of the Canadian
economy the Bank of Montreal has joined
the other big five banks in setting
aside more money for bad loans as
consumers struggle to make payment with
the High Cost of Living bimo has shed
almost $600 jobs from the previous
quarter the rest of Canada's big banks
are all making significant job Cuts as
well of between 2 to 5% of their staff
now overall the jobs picture in this
country is a bit harder to read the
Canadian economy added 25,000 new jobs
last month that's slightly more than
most economists predicted the
unemployment rate however continued to
tick higher now at
5.8% n ganguli is looking at the
employment trends and how the Bank of
Canada might respond
nearly 25,000 new
jobs that's a strong November for the
jobs Market but it's not enough to keep
Pace with Canada's Workforce which grew
by
78,000 last month still for many small
businesses finding the right Talent is
not easy this economist with the
Canadian Federation of small business
tells us as of November 20123 about 53%
of Canadian small businesses uh have
reported uh that shes have uh are
injuring their growth Philip stles has
run his pet goods and toy store for
nearly 10 years now but he says it's
harder than ever to fill new positions
not a very complicated role to fill it's
uh Warehouse roles um Administration
roles back office roles um and we're
finding that attracting um qualified uh
you know staff is proving to be a
challenge right now the Canadian
Federation of small business estimates
that small businesses lost over $38
billion in Revenue due to labor
shortages last year for stles the loss
is personal without good Staffing we
really struggle to grow we struggle to
um increase our capacity and gain more
business and that restriction um within
the workforce really holds us back from
uh you know bigger and better things
though strong wage growth can raise
concerns around inflation econom IST say
that higher unemployment and an
unexpected drop in GDP mean that the
Bank of Canada will hold interest rates
steady next week Deja de's Randall
Bartlet is one of those predicting a
rate hold we are seeing uh we take a
trend toward uh gradually um gradually
cooling uh inflation in Canada and a
weakening of the labor market both of
which point to uh the Bank of Canada
staying on the sidelines at its December
meeting and we think the Bank of Canada
will ultimately stay on hold until
cutting in the second quarter of 2024
Nita ganguli Global News
Toronto the cop 28 un climate Summit is
officially underway in Dubai King
Charles long known for his environmental
activism gave the opening speech unless
we rapidly repair and restore Nature's
unique Economy based on Harmony and
balance our own economy and
survivability will be imperiled worries
me great the king also warned the world
remains dreadfully far off track in
tackling climate change un Secretary
General Antonio gues enforced that
saying countries are still miles from
achieving the 2015 Paris agreement
goals a un report already criticized
Canada last month calling it the country
with the widest gap between what it
promises and actual climate action
Abigail Bean looks at what new pledges
this country is making at the
summit kicking off 28 Nations pledged
money towards a climate disaster fund to
help poor countries battered by the
effects of climate change Canada is
providing $6 million in seed money to
the startup cost of this fund for loss
and damage a start climate Advocates say
is not enough it's just so small it's
it's a rounding error in our federal
government
budget there are more commitments
expected from Canada at the 2-e summit
many watching for a long promised oil
and gas emissions cap framework I'd be
shocked if it wasn't presented by by by
by the end of this conference we cannot
let one sector of of the economy a
sector that has been continuously
delaying disrupting and blocking climate
action sit on the bench the oil and gas
industry has long pushed back on the
effectiveness of a cap if they try I
expect we'll see court case after court
case after court case and it will you
know of course the provinces will view
it as um coming into their jurisdictions
I want anyone who's looking at making a
major investment in our Province to know
that I'm keenly interested on clearing
away any barriers Alberta and
Saskatchewan have sent their own
delegations to cop 28 Saskatchewan even
taking out ads on the Dubai Metro it
certainly isn't
helpful one of the rules Cardinal rules
and certainly as a member of Parliament
and leader of the green party here my my
job is you you're on Team Canada when
you show up at an international meeting
another promise on the cop watch list
new regulations to reduce methane
emissions in Canada's oil and gas sector
by 75% by 2030 that's expected to be
announced Monday meanwhile Elizabeth May
says it's not just reductions that are
important but better monitoring to make
sure they work Abigail Beman Global News
Ottawa kicked out of Congress coming up
the historic ejection of an American
politician
Congressman what do you say to your
constituents excuse me you guys got get
out of my less than a year after being
elected New York Republican George
Santos made a quick exit from the US
capital today after officially getting
the boot from Congress Santos becomes
just the sixth us lawmaker to be
expelled from Congress bringing an end
to one of the most controversial tenures
the house has ever seen Jackson prco
reports George Santos saw the writing on
the wall he took one last look and
walked out of Congress leaving before
his colleagues had finished voting to
show him the door the clerk will notify
the governor of the state of New York of
the action of the house you guys got to
let him you guys got to let him in the
elevator even by Washington standards
Santos represented a whole new level of
dysfunction you know what as
unofficially already no longer a member
of Congress caught lying about
everything from his resume to the death
of his mother to his religion I always
joke I'm Catholic but I'm also Jewish
George what's going on here the real
trouble began this year when he was
indicted on 23 federal charges accused
of Fraud and stealing his own donor's
credit card numbers the reality is is
it's a witch hun where did the money go
Botox injections luxury goods even the
adult website only fans according to a
congressional ethics report which also
found Santos lied about his own wealth
you sir are a crook half of the members
of his own party wanted him gone at this
point Republicans are really concerned
about how they're going to look to the
voting public next year the Republicans
know that he he is not good publicity
and they want to get rid of him it's all
theater it's theater for the cameras
it's theater for the microphones Santos
repeatedly refused to resign but
eventually vowed not to seek reelection
if I leave they win if I leave the
bullies take place this is bullying his
defense is that he hasn't actually been
convicted of a crime not that it matters
much now with his career in shambles and
the court of public opinion firmly
turned against him Santos will quickly
be replaced after a special election in
his district do you have anything to say
to your constituents leaving behind a
world of politics that's not exactly sad
to see him go Jackson prosco Global News
Washington ahead what's putting the flow
of weapons and resources to Ukraine at
risk
[Music]
cold weather is settling in on the front
lines of Ukraine's war with Russia with
electricity and gas and short supply
Ukrainian police are bringing stoves to
people in towns desperate for warmth
Ukrainian President volodimir zalinski
says the war has reached a new stage
with winter expected to hinder the
progress a summer counter offensive
failed to produce meaningful results and
the conflict between Israel and Hamas is
now complicating efforts to secure
resources and support but as Mackenzie
gray reports zinsky insists Ukraine will
not back
down a presidential visit to the front
lines Vladimir zalinsky awarding medals
to Ukrainian troops in Kuban of course
emotionally they need some support I
think it's
very that support internationally
starting to wne after the Israel Hamas
conflict has taken up considerable
Western
attention Z conceding only the blind
could not recognize the impact the
Middle East conflict is having on
Ukraine but urging the world not to
forget about the war in his country so
much Mak a message backed up by the head
of NATO the NATO doesn't have the luxury
of only being able to address one
challenge at the time we need to be able
to address different
challenges NATO member Hungary
challenging Ukraine's bid to join the
European
Union potential negotiations to join the
block are not in hungary's National
interest says prime minister Victor
Orbin who's considered one of Russian
President Vladimir Putin's closest
allies the leader of the conservatives
is cozying up to Russian dictator
Vladimir Putin a similar claim leveled
against Canadian conservatives by the
Liberals this week after Tories voted
against updating the Canada Ukraine Free
Trade Agreement because they say it
would impose a carbon tax on ke these
issues about carbon pricing didn't
really come up the Ukrainian Canadian
Congress pushing back noting the
agreement does not force a carbon tax
and even if it did Ukraine has had one
in place since 2011 it's clear sort of
what the text of the argu the text of
the the agreement says and then what
Ukraine itself is saying the UCC has now
ridden directly to piev asking for the
conservatives to reconsider their
opposition to the deal far but even if
they don't it's still likely to pass the
House of
Commons Mackenzie gry and Ottawa thank
you
McKenzie next lucky lottery winner is
cashing in and spreading kindness
winning $100,000 in the lottery is a big
deal even if it doesn't go as far as
most of us would like in this economy
for one Nova Scotia couple though it's
enough to set their minds at ease after
being Ren evicted last year as Heidi
petruk explains they're using their
prize to pay it forward in a province
struggling with homelessness Bertram and
Helen drover felt the Panic of being Ren
evicted last year we didn't know where
we were going to go
we had we had three weeks and you think
well am I going to have to pitch a tent
and then you think oh my God where do I
go what do I do when they found this
last minute rental it was a big relief a
year later someone ahead of them in line
at the drive-thru paid for their coffees
one night they parked to drink them
across from a nearby tent encampment and
felt a wave of inspiration and I said to
Helen Helen you know if we ever won any
amount of money I think I would like to
do something for these folks call it
fate or good luck but they say something
special happened when they bought a
lottery ticket that very same night and
she actually got a little bit extra for
the ticket because she had a winner of
$2 in her hand anyway so she went even
bigger than normal they played the
Atlantic tag and won the ticket upgrade
earning them
$100,000 of course that took my breath
away so they've helped family paid off
their own bills put away for retirement
how you doing good how are you and they
tell us they used some of their winnings
to to buy small propane tanks to keep
residents at that same encampment warm
this winter maybe somebody else will
hear it somebody else will want to chip
in you don't know where this you know
that happens to people in a in a minute
in a year in a week anything is possible
so I just think that they need help
sharing Good Fortune with strangers they
say has felt better than getting the
Good Fortune itself Heidi pic Lower
Sackville Nova
Scotia the world needs more people like
the Drovers that's global national for
this Friday I'm farer and tonight your
Canada feels like it's straight out of
Australia he's fast no that's not your
eyes deceiving you that's a kangaroo on
the loose in oshaa Ontario police were
alerted to it by several sightings early
this morning it was apparently on the
way to a zoo in Quebec when it escaped
its handlers for now The Fugitive
marsupial is still at large thanks for
watching until tomorrow take care of
yourselves and take care of each other
each other good
[Music]
night